- Hey, guys, it's Justine.
And we're back, talking
more about the iPhone 8,
and I am getting so excited.
I feel like there's
these waves that I go on
when it's time for a
new iPhone to come out.
We'll have the initial rumors.
I start getting really excited,
and then, I start getting
a little bit disappointed
by the things that I see.
And then, as we near closer,
we get to see the actual things
that may just turn out
to be the real phone
that will soon be announced.
So, by now, you guys have probably seen.
There's three different colors
that have been going around,
and this MacRumors video,
I was just watching.
This is their hands on with
an iPhone 8 dummy model.
I love MacRumors.
I've said this so many times.
I've been following them
for such a long time,
and they have my heart.
So, this here is the silver version,
which I am super, super into.
For the past couple of years,
I've went the route of the black phone
because I wanted the all black face.
And there were rumors
that they were going
to have the black face
so that everything would be super flushed.
But as most of these leaks,
they're pretty much
confirming that it's not.
There still will be a white front to it.
Unless, of course, you
get the black phone.
But man, just take a look at this.
At first, I was a little bit,
eh, hesitant, you would say,
with the vertical camera.
I'm still slightly hesitant
because it looks like it's gonna be raised
way more than this one.
And since it is vertical,
that's gonna kind of mess up
the orientation of your phone
when you're setting it down.
So, the latest confirmations
is that the phone
will have facial recognition,
and I'm super excited about that.
Because I've talked a lot before
about how much I really enjoy
the Samsung Galaxy S8's
facial recognition feature
because it is quick; it's fast.
You hold your phone up, and it's unlocked.
The one question that I have, though,
is if somebody kills you,
and then, you're dead,
and then, they hold the
phone up to your face,
will it unlock the phone?
My question to you guys is
do you like this front bezel?
Do you like having the white outline
or would you prefer it to be all black?
You know my thoughts.
This is the way to go.
It's seamless; it's
beautiful; it looks nice.
I also just installed the Beta 7.
It's running so much faster.
I had a lot of issues with Beta 5.
And when I was trying to
update to the iOS 11 Beta 6,
it kept freezing on the update,
and it wouldn't actually work.
So, now that they launched the 7,
everything seems to be good, which means
we are getting closer,
and closer, and closer,
to a new iPhone.
Ooh, look at that, looks good.
Love it, I'm super into it.
So, I love this comparison
because you can see the screen
difference between the two.
And even though that
doesn't look like a lot
of screen real estate, it is.
And these are our three color options.
It kinda looks like we have
our jet black, a silver,
and this color.
I don't know what to call it.
It's copper; it's not rose gold.
I don't like this color at all.
I'm just gonna be 100%
completely honest with you,
and that's fine because
everybody has their own opinion.
And I'm sure some people are gonna be so,
so into this copper; I'm not.
The rose gold was a great look,
but apparently, this is
something that they wanna do.
So, uh, I guess, cool.
Here's another leak from
my lovely MacRumors.
These are some of the internals,
which really, you know, some
people might be into that,
which I am, but I'm not really 100% sure
of what I'm looking at.
I just want to know:
when can I have it, how
much is it gonna be?
And, am I gonna have to sleep outside?
"The new facial recognition
scanner with 3-D sensors
can deeply sense a user's face
in millionths of a second."
Not even sure how to really quantify that,
other than it sounds really freaking fast.
I am pretty accustomed to using this
because I do use it on my Surface Studio.
And, like I said, on my S8.
So, it's gonna be pretty interesting
to see what it's like on the iPhone.
And what is Apple gonna do differently?
How are they gonna make
it something different?
Or are they not?
Is it just gonna be basically like
what everyone else is doing?
No Touch ID at all?
Is that what I'm- when was this posted?
Two hours ago?
Wait a minute.
I've missed some things.
I haven't kept up this past
week because I was traveling.
So, what the heck is this?
An umbilical cord, what is this?
This is something that I- what is this?
What is this?
Ugh, oh, my God.
I can't unsee it; I can't unsee it.
Close, quit, get out of my sight!
I feel like we've already
come to the conclusion
that there's not gonna be
a physical Touch ID button
in the front, but does
that mean that Touch ID,
fingerprint sensor, is completely gone?
I wanna be able to touch;
I wanna be able to touch.
What if I don't wanna use my face?
What if I can't get into my phone
because something happens to my face,
and it no longer is my face.
Well, I guess we won't know
until the actual announcement
of what's true and what's actually legit.
I mean, I just am still- I'm
shook about this copper color.
I'm hoping that it'll look
a lot better in person,
if this is in fact the color line-up
that they're going to be going with.
I was also reading another
article where they said that
the 7s is gonna be coming
in these three colors,
and it will have no cameras.
But, I just, I know I made
a video before talking about
just being super distraught about rumors.
I don't like them.
I don't like them in real life.
I don't like them when
it comes to the iPhone.
But yet, I absolutely love them,
and I can't live without them,
and it's one of my most
favorite things to do,
is just sit online and read about.
iPhone 8 leaks, ah!
I was also thinking,
are they gonna call it the iPhone 8?
Are they gonna call it
something different?
I have this weird feeling
that they're not gonna
call it the iPhone 8.
But if that's the case,
this design isn't that
crazy of a difference
from what we've been used to
this past year, with the 7.
How do you do something that is different
than anything that we already have?
Other than implants.
I don't know; I'll do it.
I am 100% down with
donating my body to science.
You don't even have to ask me twice.
Here's a few other cool renders.
Man, what color do I get?
I'm definitely not getting the copper.
I mean, maybe I'll get
it just for a video?
I don't even wanna get it for a video,
but I feel like I'm gonna have to,
just so I can show it to you guys.
I just don't think Apple
would release something
that's not super cool.
It's gotta look better
in person; it's got to.
Or maybe they just tricked
us, and leaked that,
so that people would think
that that's what it's gonna be.
This stuff really messes with your mind.
Well, I guess that's it.
I guess in the meantime,
I'll just keep watching
this MacRumors video
over this beautiful baby boy, or girl.
I'll put a link in the description
if you guys wanna watch this
full video in its entirety.
I really just wanted to
get your guys' thoughts.
What do you think of that copper color?
Do you think this is an actual,
legit thing that's happening?
Do you think it's a temporary design?
Do you think it's a fake leak?
When do you think the
Apple event is gonna be?
Will I get an invite?
I don't know; I would drop everything.
I'll just start walking now to San Jose,
or Palo Alto, or wherever it is.
I will start walking now
to get there in time,
but I'm not sure when it is.
I would count my steps
with my Apple Watch.
Something else that I'm
super excited about,
even though that this video
is supposed to be over,
a watch that will have LTE,
but I'm still a little bit skeptical
because you probably won't
be able to make calls
from your wrist.
And if your watch is constantly searching
for an LTE connection,
I feel like that's gonna kill the battery.
This already has pretty
much a day battery life,
so they'll have to increase the battery,
plus, increase the price,
and then, you're gonna have to
probably pay monthly for LTE.
Is it worth it?
I'm not sure.
Well, guys, I will see
you in my next video.
I'm just really getting
excited about the new phone,
like, it's almost time.
Like, I can almost smell the
new packaging of the iPhone 8.
I'll see you guys later.
Ah, it's so soon!
(upbeat music)